coffee on a Tuesday in block 14
crosswalk buttons what the do they work
all right so time pretty popular belief
people do walk in Los Angeles I come
across a crosswalk button almost every
day it usually goes like this I hit the
button nothing happens then I hit it
repeatedly nothing happens then I hold
it down as if the same calm are buddies
then something happens and I feel like
this
and I realize I probably just contracted
leprosy because I've been tucking that
filthy button with my bear ski so what's
the deal is it all in my head or am i
really most check out this article from
the New York Times in 2004 for years
well-worn push buttons have offered
harried walkers a rare promise of
control over their pedestrian lives
first of all you Michael Lou I'll be
steady journalism I really really want
to write a novel later so the guests
mean that's probably the right adjective
I'm making fun of novelist it turns out
the city deactivated most of its
pedestrian buttons long ago more than
2,500 of the 30 250 watt buttons that
now exist function essentially as
mechanical placebo your mechanical
perceiver but it's true with the advent
of computer control traffic signals
cross what buttons have largely been
deactivated major cities traffic is
controlled by centralized computers
executing complex timing pet is how Seth
Green can help Mark Wahlberg get places
in his Mini Cooper but the article is
about New York what about Los Angeles so
is it is it true that there are certain
parts of the day in which the the
buttons won't affect the the light
because of the because of the because of
the complex pattern that would be the
case where there might be certain person
today where it's gonna turn green on its
own timing regardless whether somebody
hits the button or not because you know
say if it's rush hour they want to get
the cars oh sure
so placebos are everywhere yet still we
press well the short answer is humans
love button we've been conditioned all
our lives to believe that buttons do
things maybe you should just do it
it's button at crosswalks we see
ourselves pushing the button and then we
see the little white man cause and
effect who cares what's happening in
between we hit the stimulus and get the
reward that we want his tendency is
called the illusion of control it's an
idea first developed in 1975 by Ellen
Langer a professor of psychology at
heart it says that we overestimate our
ability to control here's one exam in
casinos at the craps table it's been
shown that people roll harder when they
want to get higher numbers and softer
when they want to get lower numbers even
though dice rolling unless you're George
Clooney is a chance event
Suzanne Thompson professor of psychology
from ona college says that the illusion
of control
is determined by a control heuristic is
an experience-based common sense method
of problems so the control heuristic is
based on two conditions the intention to
create the outcome the relationship
between the outcome and the action when
I press the crosswalk button I wanted to
chant it does change eventually that's
according to the control heuristic my
illusion of control is strength I'm more
likely to press it again in the field
it's this good or bad form well you have
to decide that for yourself consider
that scene with higher illusions of
control are more likely to try new
things and subsequently do new things
and those with lower loop people who are
depressed your lower illusions of
control and it's not hard to see why
when you consider their self-worth but
it has also been shown that people with
higher illusions of control are more
likely to commit to failing courses of
action it has been argued that a lack of
illusions is associated with a non
defensive personality oriented toward
growth and understanding with a low ego
involvement in outcome now I think this
point is really important first let me
say that we are Westerners in the
tradition of a Western philosophy it
means that we are doers actors believers
in the will that it can create and
changed I'm proud of that tradition and
growing up in it I know that I can never
totally be a part of Eastern philosophy
which is the opposite of though I
believe that there are things we can
change I also believe that there are
things we can one thing we can't change
is people and maybe that seems like an
obvious fact you but I think sometimes
we want it so badly that we have the
illusion that it's in our control okay
so maybe you are sure like a hundred
percent positive that someone you know
is going about something wrong well it
takes a non defensive personality to see
that it would be wrong to try to get
them to do it right it may be a little
bit counterintuitive but telling someone
what's right for them thinking that you
know what's right for them is a way of
exercising control we fail to imagine
one another complexity and in our
simplistic view think that we can handle
another's problems better than even they
its illusion we'd be better off losing I
own
and the Panda will never fulfill his
destiny not enormous until you read golf
the illusion of control
Kung Fu Panda is the best